SO GOOD TO SEE THE
YOUNGSTERS DO THEIR
INJURY, BUT BECAUSE OF
THE BREAK AND THE
COVID  KUEMPER,
SCORE!
THE DUCKS HAVE T
-- SHATTENKIRK.
HE'S REALLY PLAYED
WELL WITH THESE DUCKS.
BUT ALL OF THE SUDDDDS
BYRAM, TRYING TO FREE
DOES.
TO THE NUMBER 2 SPOT
IN THE PACIFIFIAMING.
ALONG THE END LINES.
IF
YOU'RE ANDRIGHETT
PASS.
NOW A RESHOT, BLOCKED
JUST LAUGHING WITH ONE
OF THE COACHES, AND
THAT STUFF CARRIES  IN
THE KEY.
MEAN,
DOES FRUSTRATION SET
IN?
BYRAM.
BURAKOVSKY.
DANCING AWAYAY IS BY H
LONESOME.
HERE'S LANDESKOG.
AVs ON THE PERIMETERT ,
SHOT AND SCORE!
DEV
YOUEMPER.
THAT WAS HUGE.E.
GIBSON, I'M TELLING
YOU.  BOARDS.
MINDS RAKE AN
EYE ON HIM.
REBOUND ABLE TO POUND
IT PAST GIBSON AND THE
TO MISS
MAYBE EIGHT, TEN
GAMES, HE DIDN'T.
HE COMES BACK AND, YOU
HOW ELITE HELINE.
SWINGS IT.
>> P
MacKINNON, RAP RAN WAS
LINE, TURNING AND
FIRING AND SCORES!
PASS.
BUT FOR LOGAN
O'CONNOR, AGAIN, MOSE,